العقوبات الغربيه لاسيوم الامريكيه منها
على ايران هي ليست وليده اليوم فهذه
العقوبات بداتها واشنطن منذ عام 1979 ثم
توالت الى انضمت اليها اوروبا ايضا وحتى
يومنا هذا لا تزال العقوبات تفرض على
طهران والتي بداتها اداره الرئيس جيمي
كارتر في نوفمبر 1979 بعد استلاء طلاب
متشددين على السفاره الامريكيه في طهران
واحتجاز
رهائن واصدار وقتها كارت امرا تنفيذيا
بتجميد 8 مليارات دولار من الاصول
الايرانيه ثم جاء الرئيس
رونالدن حظر بيع الاسلحه لظهران عام
1983 مما في ذلك قطع الغيار العسكريه او
قطع الغيار العسكريه الامريكيه للجيش
اثناء الحرب الايرانيه العراقيه
وتسارعت مشاهدينا وتيره العقبات في يناير
عام 1984 بتصنيف ايران لراعيه للارهاب في
اعقاب استهداف سكنات مشاته البحريه
الامريكيه في بيروت ليعود ريجن ويفرد حظرا
على السلع والخدمات الايرانيه واكملها من
بعده كلينتون في عام 1995 بدورها استكملت
اداره جورج بوش الابن مسيره العقوبات
الامريكيه ضد ايران الذي امر عام 2005
باستهداف العقوبات لافراد والكيانات التي
تزود ايران بالتكنولوجيا النوويه واسلحه
الدمار الشامل كما استهدفت ايضا عددا من
المؤسسات والبنوك الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
اما فتره براك اوباما مشاهدين فقط مثلت
بدايه لمرحله العقوبات الشامله اذا وقع
اوباما في يوليو عام 2010 قانون العقوبات
الشامله ضد ايران
ووسع هذا القانون بشكل كبير العقوبات
الشامله ضد ايران كما اضاف انواع جديده من
العقبات واوروبا ايضا اتبعت ذات النهج في
العقوبات وابرزها عام 2012 عند موافق
الاتحاد الاوروبي على حظر وردات النفط
الايراني طبعا شراء او نقل البترول
الايراني من اوروبا او المرور عبر اوروبا
حتى وامتدت هذه العقوبات الى قطاع
التكنولوجيا والصناعات البتروكيماويه
والاصالات في مايو 2018 انها دونالد ترامب
مشاركه بلاده في خطه العمل الشامله
المشتركه للاتفاق النووي واصدر مشاهدينا
في اليوم نفسه تعليمات بالمشروع والشروع
في خطوات لاعاده فرض جميع العقوبات
الامريكيه التي تم رفعها او التنازل عنها
نتيجه طبعا للاتفاق النوويه الايراني
واضاف مزيدا من هذه العقوبات ثم اتت بعد
هذه العقوبات عقوبات امريكيه واوروبيه
مؤخرا نتيجه القمع الايراني للاحتجاجات
وانتاج سياسه الاعدامات بحق المتظاهرين
السلميين وهو ما زاد الامر سوء لطهران
واذا ما جلس طبعا مستقبلا مع الغرب على
طاولات المفاوضات
[موسيقى]